[Musik]
herzlich willkommen vor 20 jahren
erschütterte ein verstörender
kriminalfall unsere gemüter zwei
menschen treffen sich der eine möchte
den körper des anderen stück für stück
auf essen der andere liegt ein der täter
ist als kannibale von rotenburg in die
geschichte eingegangen und sitzt seither
in haft der kriminalfall gilt als einer
der markantesten in der deutschen
justizgeschichte
mein heutiger gast hat soeben einen
roman über diesen kriminalfall
veröffentlicht er heißt rot hunger und
der erste satz des buches lautet das ist
eine liebesgeschichte
herzlich willkommen in santa marta rocha
danke für das ja was hat den
kannibalismus mit liebe zu tun
ich glaube wenn wir uns auf den mund
schauen und die redewendungen betrachten
und das gilt nicht nur für das deutsche
in denen wir begierde liebe hungern er
ausdrücken dann können wir vielleicht
eine spur finden die beide themen
miteinander verbindet wir sagen ich habe
dich zum fressen gern wir sagen aber
eine idee und wir sagen ja im semi und
in vielen sprachen bitte gering sind ich
möchte dich essen ja auf türkisch in
vielen sprachen wird der hunger nach
dieser nähe durch diese kannibalischen
formeln ausgedrückt und das ist
eigentlich das gefühl was diesem roman
vorausgegangen ist nicht der
kriminalfall nicht die sensation der
spektakel nicht die moralischen
spekulationen auch nicht die
psychologischen vermutungen sondern das
gefühl dass wir alle kennen auf dem
schoß eines menschen zu liegen denn wir
lieben oder dieser menschlicher von zur
brust und
wir empfinden diesen abstand dass dieser
mensch immer noch zu weit entfernt ist
und ich würde sagen dass der mensch den
wir lieben der abwesende mensch von
allen ist weil er nie nah genug sein
kann
also der mensch den wir lieben ist er
entfernt dass der der abwesende mensch
weil wir zu ihnen die größte sehnsucht
nach nähe verspüren so genau und diese
formulierungen weisen eigentlich darauf
dass wir diese grenze die unser körper
ist anatomisch und so haut unser fleisch
unserer knochen dass sie die ja
eigentlich diesen anderen menschen und
uns definiert dass diese grenze jetzt im
weg steht und dass wir bereits sind
zumindest wenn wir uns versprach
vertrauen und ihr so viel vertrauen
schenkt wir wollen diese grenze
aufzuheben und woher kommt diese
sehnsucht nach verschmelzung nach
vereinigungen mit einem anderen dass die
wurzeln ich kann nicht sagen was die
wurzel ist es gibt sicherlich viele
spekulationen sie kennen wahrscheinlich
dieses berühmte bild der kugel menschen
dass platon entwirft in seinem symposium
das s3 geschlechter gab die alle am
rücken miteinander verbunden gewesen
waren nämlich einmal die man männer dann
die frau frauen und die man frauen und
diese menschen hatten ja vier arme sie
hatten vier beine und die götter waren
so ängstlich vor ihnen für ihre kraft
und ihre macht dass sie die menschen
auseinander gerissen haben und seither
so lautet diese platonische mythos seien
diese menschen auf der suche nach dem
stück das in den verloren gegangen ist
ich würde sagen und das ist für mich
auch aus seinen taschen perspektive die
wesentliche einsicht was ist eigentlich
wenn wir einsamkeit als einen modus
unsere existenziellen verfasstheit
verstehen und das nicht nur in bezug auf
liebe nicht nur in bezug auf
gemeinschaft auf gesellschaft sondern
auch in bezug auf das andere große g
nämlich gott und dieser roman versucht
in verschiedenen variationen diese
traurigen versuche eine verbindung
herzustellen eine verbindung einzugehen
sie zu beschreiben ihnen nachzugehen bis
zu dem punkt an dem sie nur in einer
weiteren enttäuschung und ernüchterung
enden werden der psychoanalytiker erich
fromm schreibt ja dass die einsamkeit
eigentlich dass das getrennt sein vom
anderen und von anderen das grundproblem
der menschlichen existenz ist also diese
diese einsamkeit dieses alleinsein
letztlich und dass der ursprung ist auch
was von liebe das was wir überwinden
wollen in lebach und klauten in
der suche nach ekstase drogenkonsums das
ist das ganz ursprüngliche bedürfnisse
ich glaube dass er durch form errichtet
aber ich möchte sagen was ist wenn wir
einsamkeit nicht unbedingt als ein
problem verstehen sondern erst einmal
als 11 modus wir sind in diese welt
geworfen wurden wir alle sind geboren
wurden und ohne unser einverständnis
gegeben zu haben und wir stehen vor den
dingen mit ja diesem stündlichen staunen
und diesem wunder dass das die welt ist
und wir versuchen uns in bezug zu setzen
wir versuchen sprachlich durch unseren
körper ein selbst unterwelt verhältnis
zu entwickeln und wir sehen aber auch
dass die welt nach einem anderen gesetz
funktioniert dass unsere bedürfnisse
enttäuscht werden manchmal auch zu recht
und was ich mich frage ist was passiert
wenn wir diese einsamkeit
aus ihr eine andere form von potentially
töpfen das könnte das heißen ich möchte
vielleicht ein anderes beispiel nehmen
um darauf hinzuweisen wie wir vielleicht
diese einsamkeit verstehen können in der
westlichen philosophie aber auch in
unserem denken in unserem alltags denken
stellen wir uns das nichts als die
abwesenheit aller dinge vor wir werden
eigentlich mathematisch verfahren wenn
wir diesen nichts eine form eine
vorstellung geben wollen wir
subtrahieren alles was in diesem raum
ist aus diesem raum alle materiellen
gegenstände alle menschen die diesen
raum bevölkern und dann nehmen wir sogar
raum und zeit dass was kant in der
kontinental ästhetik die sinnliche
formen seiner anschauung apriori also
die grundbedingungen für einen
physikalischen raum dass dinge in diesem
raum sein können auch das nehmen wir aus
diesem raum
heraus und wir stellen uns vor dass das
das nichts ist also das gegenteil von
sein aber ich würde sagen
was passiert wenn wir das nichts nicht
als abwesenheit aller dinge sondern als
die möglichkeit die noch um
verwirklichte fülle aller dinge
verstehen und so muss das ja auch
gewesen sein als gott das erste wort
gesprochen hat in diesem nichts was
diesem ersten wort vorausgegangen ist in
seinem warten in seinem zögern
vielleicht auch in seinen bedenken war
alles schon da alles was ist und alles
was einmal geworden sein wird und so
können wir vielleicht auch den urknall
verstehen und dieser begriff urknalls
führt uns hier auch in die falsche
richtung weil er ja um etwas zu hören
brauchen wir raum und zeit das heißt es
muss etwas gegeben haben was nicht sein
ist aber was dieses sein als möglichkeit
später wirklichkeit wird schon
inbegriffen hat und so möchte ich diesen
begriff der einsamkeit auch verstehen
was passiert wenn wir ihn nicht als
problem begreifen sondern als eine
möglichkeit uns anders in verbindung zu
setzen und zwar nicht nach den
konventionen nicht nach den dogmen und
nicht nach den traditionen sie hatten
gott und den glauben jetzt schon zwei
mal angesprochen und man sieht dass sie
tragen gut sich bei an ein kreuz was hat
dieses kreuz mit dieser ursprünglichen
sehnsucht zu tun nach nach
verschmelzungen die die in der liebe
spüren für sie ich bin aufgewachsen in
einer religiösen und ich kann auch sagen
in einer sehr konservativ religiösen
familie mein vater ist nach der flucht
84 zum christentum konvertiert er war
zeuge jehovas als sri lanka sonst ist
die familie geflohen darüber werden wir
gleich noch reden genau vor dem
bürgerkrieg vor dem genozid an uns
terminen der krieg der von 383 bis 2009
also 26 jahre andauerte und bis zu
300.000 menschenleben gekostet hat und
meine mutter ist bis heute hin mein
vater hat
in diesem monat mai 2009 als der krieg
zu ende gingen seinen glauben verloren
und ich bin aufgewachsen in einer
familie in der beide symbole einmal die
symbolik die mitte vorrückte poetik des
christentums aber auch des hinduismus
ich gleichermaßen anwesend waren und sie
haben sich nicht widersprochen sondern
beide dinge konnten gleichzeitig wahr
sein die nagas in der hinduistischen
mythologie schlangen gottheiten also
sakrale heilige lebewesen aber die
schlange ist im christentum als die
personifikation des teufels sehr
deutlich negativ besetzt und ich musste
mich nicht entscheiden beides kann
gleichzeitig wahr sein
ich war im gegensatz zu meinen beiden
geschwistern ich bin das mittlere kind
immer sehr interessiert aber auch offen
bis zu dem punkt eigentlich des
fanatischen lesens ich wollte wissen was
dieses wort ist ich wollte wissen woher
dieses wort von gott stand und ich
wollte wissen was es eigentlich für mich
bedeutet wir müssen wir verstehen dass
das christentum eine poetik ist am
anfang war das wort und das wort war bei
gott bei gott dieses wort ist aber auch
gleichzeitig christus als das fleisch
geworden als das menschgewordene wort
und dass gott sich uns offenbart hat in
der schrift in der sprache aber er hat
sich gleichzeitig auch verborgen in der
schrift und in der sprache und ich kann
mich erinnern dass ich lesen und
schreiben gelernt hatte vor meiner
einschulung durch einen bruder aus
unserer versammlung und das erste wort
was den beiden zeugen jehovas zeugen
jehovas und das erste wort was ich
gelernt hatte war nicht mein name sowie
das kinder normalerweise tun das erste
wort was wir zu schreiben lernen was er
auch eine politische dimension
eigentlich hat wir lernen zuerst unser
namen zu schreiben sondern den namen
gottes und die zeugen jehovas haben ja
darauf bestanden und sie tun es bis
heute dass sie im gegensatz zu anderen
religionen den wahren namen gottes
kennen also habe ich jehova geschrieben
und von diesem j aus konnte ich auch
jesus schreiben
und dieses j das war für mich in einer
art auch der arm gottes der vom himmel
bis unter die erde unter die zeile
greift weil alles aussehen kommt aus
diesem nichts und aus diesem ersten wird
also wo war gott war ihr erstes wort in
deutschland überhaupt des wortes
schreiben konnten und vor kurzem
wir waren beim kreuz bei äußerlichkeiten
wir sehen ob sie haben tattoos auf dem
unterarm haften auf den fingern und auf
den eigenen beinen steht
jhw h
wann haben sie dieses tattoo gemacht
warum die sie die hände kurz dahin
halten dass wir sehen danke diese linien
habe ich in los angeles stechen lassen
2017 ich habe eine kurze zeit dort als
stipendiat der villa gelebt und ich
hatte einen freund besucht in washington
und in der national gallery of art stand
ich in diesem raum es war sonntag und es
hatte geregnet november ich war ganz
alleine dort drei wände die mich umfasst
hatten und dieser zyklus hieß stations
auf der cross in klammern lena sabah
thani ein zyklus von benetton jungen
einem amerikanischen maler der den
abstrakten expressionismus zugeordnet
wird und auf diesen 14 gemälden konnte
man immer nur eine vertikale linie sehen
barnett newman wollte nicht die via
dolorosa dem leidensweg christi
darstellen sondern und lena sabah thani
dieser untertitel heißt auf aramäisch
mein gott mein gott warum hast du mich
verlassen eli lilly masse batterie
sondern diesen einen momente absoluten
verlassenheit wir könnten auch sagen der
absoluten einsamkeit barnet niemand
beschreibt diese linie als das sip und
er meint damit sap partner getrennt sein
wir könnten vielleicht so weit gehen und
sagen einsamkeit und er sagt wenn jemand
diese linie sieht möge dieser mensch
nicht nur die einsamkeit die sap
partners die gesundheit von barnett
newman sehen sondern auch die eigene
also bin ich nach los angeles zurück
geflogen und habe mir diese linien
stechen lassen und nachdem ich diesen
zweiten roman beendet hatte kurz vor der
veröffentlichung vor einigen monaten im
februar habe ich beschlossen auch als
ein zeichen des dankes aber auch als ein
zeichen der demut und ich glaube um den
unterschied zwischen demut und
demütigung zu können müssen wir uns
manchmal auch demütigen lassen und
schreiben ist für mich eine form der
demütigung habe ich mir dann hier einmal
auf alt hebräisch den namen gottes
tätowieren lassen die lateinischen
buchstaben und darunter auf tami der
sprache meine eltern die sprache des
tamilischen volkes abmelde keine angst
ich wusste wenn ich diesen mann überlebe
dann gibt es keinen grund mehr angst zu
haben
je nach davon dass sie diesen roman
überlebt haben dass es den
schreibprozess überlebt haben dass sie
ich hatte meinen glauben verloren mit 13
und dennoch anders als meine beiden
geschwister hatte das christentum mich
immer noch beschäftigt ich würde so weit
gehen und sagen verfolgt in den predigen
von von bahnhöfe gibt es immer diese
merkwürdige dunkelheit und diese
dunkelheit eröffnet uns eine andere
nacht beschreibt gott zum beispiel als
ein schatten der uns nicht mehr loslässt
die liebe sei so stark wie der tod und
das in seinen predigten
und ich wusste dass ich irgendwie immer
noch in diesem winkel stehe den die
heilige schrift mehr öffnet hat deswegen
habe ich auch theologie studiert und
auch überlegt pfarrer zu werden aber es
hat mir glauben gefehlt nicht unbedingt
an religiosität nicht unbedingt an nähe
zu dieser sprache zu diesen symbolen
aber an der aufrichtigkeit und auch an
dem aufrechten gang in dieser schrift
aber
gleichzeitig als ich meinen ersten roman
geschrieben hatte habe ich sehr deutlich
diesen traum
empfunden dass die ästhetische erfahrung
eigentlich eine religiöse erfahrung sein
muss und der erste roman gab anlass zu
diesem gedanken weil der erste roman
diesen zaun nicht einhalten dieses
versprechen nicht einhalten konnte aber
als ich diesen summen als er zu mir kam
ich kann es nicht anders sagen wie ja
wie ein brennender busch der brennt da
wird er nicht verbrennt wusste ich dass
mein ganzes leben gemeint ist dass sich
37 jahre nur gelebt habe um diesen roman
zu schreiben und dass ich diesen roman
schreiben muss um zu wissen dass die
ästhetische erfahrung eine religiöse
erfahrung ist und das schreiben für mich
beten ist eine form des gebetes und
dieser roman ist genau das ein gebiet
ein gesang also ein gedicht man spürt
schon wenn man ihnen zuhört sie sind ein
existenzieller denke an schriftsteller
sehr philosophische metaphysisch sie
haben auch philosophie studierte
evangelische theologie wie sie gesagt
haben kulturwissenschaften der erste
roman trägt den titel vor der zunahme
der zeichen der erschien 2016
vielfach preisgekrönt und gelobt
und jetzt dieser neue roman über den wir
auch noch ein bisschen und sie
versprechen werden und denis scheck
vielleicht der bekannteste
literaturkritiker deutschlands meinte
dazu es sei ein meisterwerk wie fühlt
sich das an
wissen sie ich schreibe von niemanden
und ich schreibe nur in dieses nichts
hinein das hat einen ganz einfachen
grund und das muss ich noch einmal auf
die bibel zurück kommen wenn ich das
alttestamentliche wilde verbot ernst
nehmen dass wir uns kein bildnis machen
dürfen von gott aber wenn es wie es im
psalm heißt war sein soll dass gott uns
auch nur ein wenig geringer gemacht hat
als ich selbst dann dürfen wir uns auch
von keinem menschen ein bildnis machen
und wenn ich an ein publikum denke
während ich schreibe dann korrumpiert
dieses antizipierte publikum diesen text
das heißt um die integrität des textes
zu wahren darf ich mir kein bildnis
machen der menschen die diesen text
einmal lesen könnten die adressiert sein
möchten und der text darf nicht das
ebenbild dieses bildnisses sein das hat
ganz einfache praktische konsequenzen
wenn autorin ein schriftsteller innen
gefragt werden für wen sie schreiben
dann nennen sie eine altersgruppe
das schlecht klasse und all diese
kategorien die der betriebswirtschaft
seine target ordens beitragen sind für
mich nicht nur
kapitalistische kategorien sondern auch
kategorien in denen sexistische
klassische rassistische vor einnahmen
von einem möglichen publikum eingegangen
sind und so wird dieses buch
zugerichtet und mögliche wirkliche
menschen die dieses buch einmal lesen
könnten dieses buch wird diese menschen
nicht erreichen als ich meine vierte
lesung hatte im april 2016 in bielefeld
in einer buchhandlung mit meinem ersten
roman
hatte mich kurz davor mein lektor
gefragt für wen ich dieses buch
geschrieben habe und ich sagte ich
wüsste das nicht das spielt für mich
auch keine rolle ob dieses buch
irgendwann mal gelesen wird aber
trotzdem wollten sie das publizieren
ja ich glaube er daran auch das
weil ein text sprachlich verfasst ist
ist er zugänglich ich sage es nur sind
wir bereit
diese geduld aufzubringen
aber das heißt nicht dass dieser text
gleichzeitig adressiert ist in diesem
bestimmten sind sprache adressiert und
sie spricht uns an und wissen sie bei
dieser lesung bielefeld nach der lesung
kam ein mann zu mir 63 jahre vielleicht
und ich sah wie emotional war und er
sagte seine eltern campus schlesien
und als kind hat er so viele fragen und
niemand wollte im antwort geben und
jetzt seien die menschen die mir
antworten können schon längst verstorben
und der soll so allein mit diesen fragen
zu einsam mit den sätzen die niemandem
gegenüber aussprechen kann und dann
sagte er zu mir danke dass sie ihre
sprachlosigkeit befunden haben und ist
gegangen ich habe meine sprachlosigkeit
nicht überwunden aber was ich sagen
möchte ist wenn ich an eine target
ordens gedacht hätte und diesen roman
geschrieben hätte für ein publikum nach
diesen bestimmten maßstäben dann hätte
er diese man dies nun mal niemals
gelesen und ich glaube so müssen wir uns
vielleicht auch das verhältnis zur bibel
vorstellen es gibt gott der der urheber
dieser schrift sein soll was ja auch
nicht ganz wahr ist weil es von der
menschen die die heilige schrift
geschrieben haben es gibt in der
theologie diese auch nach
reformatorische theorie der verbal
inspiration dass die bibel bis in den
wortlaut hinein von gott eigentlich kann
was natürlich die frage nach die
übersetzung noch einmal ganz anders
stellt aber ich würde sagen wenn die
bibel geschrieben worden ist auch wenn
sie durch den heiligen geist und durch
gott inspiriert worden ist in dem
strengen sinne des wortes der
inspiration dann gehen sie doch durch
die fehlbarkeit der menschlichen hände
also ist sie nicht ganz gottes wort und
sonne auf dem gottes wort zu werden und
wenn ich diesen gedanken vielleicht noch
zu ende formulieren darf und ich würde
sagen dann gibt es uns die zweite
ordnung nach den prophet innen aber
dieser text steht auch zwischen uns und
gott dieser text gehört nicht mehr gott
wer gehört auch nicht uns die bibel ist
wie jeder andere text auch ein eigener
bereich mit einem eigenen recht mit
einer eigenen autonomie und wir können
uns verbinden und das wort religare von
dem ihr auch religionen herkommt
bedeutet ja auch so sicher bin ich aber
sehr leger aber bedeutet auch beachten
sie wieder lesen als wir können immer
wieder auf diese texte zurückkehren
gerade weil sie weder zu den menschen
die als die urheber innen dieses textes
gelten gehören noch zu uns der text ist
ein eigener bereich ein eigener bezirk
und hat immer sein eigenes recht
ich möchte mich diese nach wissen über
ihre biografie jetzt reden dass das
menschliche leben ist ja beginnt mit
einem paradox könnte man sagen also die
die erste zeit die ersten monate und
jahre unseres lebens prägen uns am
meisten
aber sie sagt die zeit an die wir uns
kamen oder gar nicht erinnern bei ihnen
ist das eine traumatische kindheit
gewesen also die familie geflohen erst
der vater weiß und 84 dann die mutter
mit ihnen aus vier monate alten kind und
mit dem älteren bruder
und die ersten jahre haben sie dann in
flüchtlingsheimen asylbewerber haben in
deutschland verbracht die ersten sieben
jahre
was hat diese flucht erfahren die ersten
jahre ihres lebens an die sie sich nicht
erinnern mit ihnen gemacht wir haben
diese geprägt wissen sie ich würde sagen
heute und je älter ich werde umso umso
weniger verstehe ich meine eltern aber
umso näher fühle ich mich ihnen und als
ich an jugendliche war war ich nicht
bereit diese ganzen geschichten zu hören
und meine eltern haben das gilt
vielleicht für viele menschen die diese
dinge gesehen haben kaum darüber
gesprochen
dass sprechen wir immer auch ein modus
der verleugnung des verschweigens des
vereins des verdrängens das ja des
vergessens und ich würde immer sagen wir
müssen dankbar sein dass die natur oder
gott die natur durch gott
uns die gnade des vergessens gegeben hat
wie wenig an wie wenig können wir uns
erinnern von den vergangenen 24 stunden
und was würden wir tun wenn wir uns
immer an alles erinnern könnten wir
könnten nicht leben unser körper werde
nicht dafür gemacht und dennoch auch
dass es ja eine paradoxe situation die
erinnerung kommt aus dem vergessen aus
der namenlosen tiefe des gedächtnisses
und nur das vergessen ist stark genug um
unsere erinnerung wirklich zu ertragen
und
meine eltern hatten uns und dass es für
mich eigentlich ein wunder eine so
glückliche kindheit ermöglicht gerade
weil all diese dinge nicht präsent war
ja der tod war anwesend wie ein bruder
in unserer familie aber mit der
selbstverständlichkeit und nicht mit dem
ungeheuerlichen
dass wir mit dem tod in verbindung
bringen all diese dinge die meine eltern
so stark mitgenommen haben und sie
können sich vorstellen sind in dieses
land gekommen und
konnten diese sprache nicht kann
niemanden und waren sichtbar mit dunkle
haut in diesem kleinen bayerischen dorf
in das wir geschickt wurden sind nach
denen in berlin angekommen sind und
für mich ist das bis heute nicht
nachvollziehbar dass meine eltern es
geschafft haben drei vier schichten am
tag zu arbeiten
und dass wir nicht von diesem unglück
von diesem horror und dem tod der uns
vorausgegangen ist in unserer kindheit
etwas mitbekommen haben aber trotzdem
waren da hat auch solche irrationalen
schuld und schamgefühle wie sie das
beschreiben was ich sagen zum beispiel
das gefühl wir haben keinen völkermord
überlegt damit sich mittelmäßig bleiben
darf also dieser druck auch aus ihrem
leben jetzt etwas zu machen
da sind haben sie das gespürt konkret
das kam vor allem späte aber ich kann
mich erinnern an
das ist vielleicht etwas seltsam dass
jetzt so im fernsehen zu sagen aber ich
kann mich erinnern hat sich fünf jahre
alt war und mein jüngerer geschwister
hatte ein spielzeug zerstört und ich
sollte operieren
ich hätte daniel düsentrieb als kind
sehr gemocht und habe auch diese
vorstellung gemacht dinge reparieren zu
können ich hab das mit ein paar
bleistiften und
kugelschreiber
wieder hinbekommen meine mutter sagte zu
mir
weißt du du bist geboren wurden um
unseren namen reinzuwaschen
du bist geboren worden damit die
menschen sichern uns erinnern ich war
fünf jahre alt wir haben noch letzten
asylbewerberheim gelebt
und ich habe nicht verstanden was das
bedeutet aber je älter ich werde umso
öfter sagt meine mutter
meine prophezeiung ist wahr geworden
aber zu welchem preis und
das ist ja auch was nicht immer wieder
beschäftigt ich habe nicht eingewilligt
zu diese vorhersage und was war der
preis
der preis für dieses buch war natürlich
mein leben
und es ist schwer über diese dinge zu
sprechen über die religiösen erfahrungen
aber auch die ästhetischen erfahrungen
als religiöse erfahrungen weil weil sie
kaum nachvollziehbar geworden sind wir
müssen verstehen dass kapitalismus
gerade ja dazu führt wenn menschen von 9
bis 18 uhr arbeiten dass sie nicht die
zeit haben in die tiefe ihres
gedächtnisses zu schauen sich
auseinanderzusetzen mit der anarchie in
ihrem unbewussten und ich glaube für
künstler innen ist das angebot das zu
tun nicht stellvertretend aber um uns
daran zu erinnern wie viel an ihm ali t
und vielleicht auch qualität in uns
liegen könnte und wie nahe beides
vielleicht beieinander
und als ich diesen roman geschrieben
habe war ich in einem zustand der
absoluten
ja ich kann das nicht anders beschreiben
als ein zustand der für mich ein
mystischer zustandes ein zustand der
mystischen erfahrungen der mystischen
offenheit es gibt keinen tag an dem ich
nicht bereit war mir das leben zu nehmen
aussagen wie siehst du das zustand der
völligen selbstaufgabe also was ist
auflösung also verstehen sie wenn wie
melitta tour reden ich bin vielleicht
mehr schriftsteller als philosoph und
mehr schriftstellers theologe dann
begegnet uns sehr auf diese formulierung
dass sprach ein instrument des erzählens
ist das gilt vor allem für klose
autorinnen die das mit einer routine
sagen
aber ein instrument für die auch dazu
dass wir die sprache
instrumentalisieren wir nutzen sie in
unserem sinn und zu unseren zwecken aber
wenn es wahr ist dass gottes wort ist
wenn es wahr ist dass gott sich uns
offenbart und verborgen hat in der
schrift dann müsste ich doch anders über
sprache nachdenken es ist eine
allgemeine formulierung zu sagen die
sprache
führt uns in eine falsche richtung die
wörter sei nicht genug um das
auszudrücken dass zu transportieren was
wir wirklich meinen aber was ist wenn
und das ist die erfahrung dieses zweiten
mannes ich mich der sprachlichen gebe
was passiert wenn ich mich vor der
sprache aufgebe was passiert wenn ich
mich ergebe vor der sprache wenn ich
sage im vergleich zu einem wort wenn ich
nichts wenn ich sage
was ist meine einsamkeit im vergleich zu
gottes einsamkeit die dazu geführt hat
dass er uns erschaffen musste und diese
vorstellung zu sagen ich stehe im dienst
der sprache ich bin das instrument der
sprache zeigt auch eine verbindung
zwischen profi und
poetik politologie in der prophetie in
der prophezeiung ist der körper eines
menschen das instrument einer anderen
stimme und wir kennen das vielleicht
dieses gefühl wir schreiben einen satz
und wir wissen nicht wer diesen satz
geschrieben hat wir betrachten unsere
hände und so leeren hände und fragen uns
ist dieser satz wirklich durch diese
hände gekommen stammt er von diesen
händen und wir können diese frage nur
ganz deutlich mit 9 bernd und dieses
gefühl hatten sie beim schreiben dieses
romans sozusagen wie ein medium zu sein
und das sozusagen nicht sie schreiben
dieses buches scheint sich so ist es
aber ich kann auch sagen ich war nicht
gemacht für diese erfahren und es war
eine zeit der absoluten inneren und
äußeren verwüstung ich habe 20 kilo
zugenommen
verloren ich habe den roman das ende des
formates geschrieben auf der wartburg da
wo luther die bibel übersetzte
hatte der september testament 1522
veröffentlicht
nicht unter seinem namen
und 500 jahre später im oktober
1521 hat luther angefangen die bibel zu
besetzen und im oktober
2021 war ich gast der internationalen
martin luther stiftung unter deutschen
bibelgesellschaft und habe den roman
dort zu ende geschrieben
und ich erinnere mich daran an diese
masse an himmel wir waren so nah am
himmel dass sich der himmel in diesen
ganz verschiedenen variationen gezeigt
hat und ich habe mich gefragt ob es nur
möglich werfe luther diese sprache zu
finden aber auch sie zu erfinden leib
und leben
ebenbild plan vor die säue alter sind ja
formulierungen von luther in denen wir
immer noch sprechen im schweiße seines
angesichts
dass er nur möglich dass es für ihn
unmöglich war diese sprache zu finden so
nah am himmel war und gleichzeitig so
entfernt davon und ich habe teile des
romanes geschrieben in diesem zimmer das
neben luthers wie man sagt studie ist
und ein anderer berühmter eisenach ist
ja
und ich habe die chaconne in d-moll für
solo-violine nach zimmer gehört als ich
allein im hotel in der lobby saß und in
der interpretation von i zr mann und ich
schreibe immer nachts weil ich glaube
nachts ist die grenze zwischen dem
bewussten und dem unbewussten brüchige
dinge können passieren im doppelten sinn
nicht nur sie können die grenze
passieren wie meine mutter das getan hat
sondern auch dinge können sich ereignen
und der zustand der eigentlich erreicht
werden muss und das ist für mich der
mystische zustand es zeige ich eine
verkehrung zwischen dem bewussten und
dem unbewussten und dass wir
konfrontiert sind mit der absoluten
dunkelsten nacht in uns aus der nur
sprache kommen kann aus diesem nichts
das für gottes warten war das zögern und
in diesem nichts ist die ganze
wirklichkeit als möglichkeit enthalten
dieses dunkle diese abgründe diese nach
die zieht sie errang wenn man eher
instagram profil anschauen das sind
alles dunkle bilder aber es ist immer
überall auf jedem bild eine lichtquelle
zu sehen
woher kommt dieses dieses diese vorliebe
für diese art von ästhetik vielleicht
muss man dazu sagen sie schauen nach
gern gerne horrorfilme
eine einzige passion da ihre einzige
passion wie bringen sie das zusammen
wissen sie als ich meinen ersten roman
veröffentlicht habe der auch so ein
gespräch besteht zwischen zwei menschen
die aus familien die geflohen sind
kommen in einem aus dem kosovo und
einmal aus so lanker die beide einen
völkermord überlebt haben
wurde ich oft konfrontiert mit der
irritation von lese ihnen die nach
lesungen sagten wie kann es sein dass
beide protagonistinnen so kalt und
sachlich sind wenn sie diese geschichten
erzählen und
ich hatte keine antwort
bis die antwort dann später und immer
mit verzögerung kam wenn die geschichten
mit denen man aufwächst mit denen ich
aufgewachsen sind auch geschichten der
zerstörung des todes des krieges der
absoluten vernichtung des deutlichsten
nichts sind wenn diese geschichten auch
die idee der geschichte selbst und des
erzählens geprägt haben da gibt es
keinen grund emotional zusammen wenn ich
über diese dinge rede ich nicht anders
warnt selbstverständlichkeit so ist
saudischer weise und der einzige modus
in dem aber man erzählen kann und ich
glaube was durch das schreiben aber auch
durch
das studium der theologie und der
philosophie mehr der theologie für mich
geschah ist dass ich diese nacht in mir
anerkannt dass ich sie angenommen habe
und bereits sind sie zu studieren zu
erforschen aber es gibt dann ja immer
moment in meinem leben wo einen diese
dinge dann trotzdem auffallen aus
alltagsrassismus diskriminierung
demütigung die haben sie von
kindesbeinen an erlebt ein beispiel
beschreiben sie in ihrem ersten buch im
zeichenunterricht wo sie einen menschen
einen dunkelhäutigen menschen zeichen
wollten und da kam die lehrerin hat
ihnen den stift aus der hand genommen
den brandstifter und ihnen ein hellrosa
stift in die hand gelegt er mit den
worten dass sie das nennen wir hier
hautfarbe das ist nur eines der vielen
beispiele
dann können sie sich an den moment
erinnern wo ihm das zum ersten mal
auffiel dass sie anders sind und dass
sie anders behandelt
ich kann mich daran nicht erinnern
wir sind aufgewachsen meine beiden
geschwister und ich meine familie meine
eltern leben bis heute dort in einer
kleinstadt in bayern und wir waren immer
anschaubar das heißt aber auch an
schreiber an spuckte und ich kannte das
nicht anders ich kannte kein anderen
zustand außerdem dieses ausgesetzt sein
und insofern habe ich das auch nie in
frage gestellt erst als ich älter wurde
und bis heute fallen mir dinge ein mit
dem erstaunen der zauber eines kindes
das ist wirklich passiert
das ist mir widerfahren und
und das hat spuren hinterlassen
in diesem körper die ich nicht verstehe
aber ich glaube wissen sie was ist muss
es für mich
auch in diesen büchern wenn rassismus
erwähnt wird dann nicht weil ich
rassismus interessant finde aus seiner
poetischen perspektive sondern weil es
muss zu der lebensrealität gehört auch
zu meine aber was ich mich viel mehr
frage ist
zum beispiel ziehe mir von der hautfarbe
und im gesicht gesprochen was bedeutet
es für uns menschen dass wir niemals
unser gesicht sehen werden dass wir
unser gesicht kennen in form von drei
produktionen eines fotos aber dann ist
unser gesichter auch vereinfacht
verflacht verspätet wenn wir einen
spiegel schauen sehen wir uns nicht
unser gesicht wir sehen sich
spiegelverkehrt
ich frage mich was bedeutet dass ein
gesicht zu haben dass lehmann dass immer
jemand anderes sehen wird aber wir
niemals gesehen haben wir sehen schon
unsere eigenen videoaufnahmen mit
unserem eigenen blick ja aber auch
wissen sie wir sind ja auf dem video
nicht mit dreidimensional wir sind für
flacht das gesicht hat nicht mehr die
größte die unser gesicht wirklichen
sondern wir sehen niemals uns so wie wir
wirklich sind in dem augenblick nicht
verzögert nicht verspätet und das ist
was mich viel mehr interessiert aber
auch die frage nach der stimme und ich
würde sagen wir sprechen eigentlich in
drei stimmen nämlich einmal spreche ich
jetzt in dieser stimme zu ihnen und sie
hören mich persönlich anders als ich
mich höhere wir kennen ja dieses in
setzen wenn man zum ersten mal seine
stimme aufgenommen und fragt sich in das
wirklich ich ja das bin ich aber nicht
so wie ich mich kenne so nur wie andere
mich kennen und in dieser stimme würde
ich mich selbst nicht wieder erkennen
aber diese stimme die nur ich höre aus
anatomischen gründen und die für sie
nicht hörbar ist die bleibt bei mir
und niemand anderes könnte sie bezeugen
wir glauben dass sie wirklich existiert
und dann gibt es die stimme in uns in
der wir lesen in der wir beten in der
wir zu gott sprechen vielleicht auch zu
uns selbst und ich frage mich viel mehr
anders als rassismus rassismus ist ein
sehr einfacher mechanismus es gibt kein
geheimnis in diese barbarei ich frage
mich viel mehr was bedeutet es wenn wir
unsere einsamkeit als eine existenzielle
verfasstheit akzeptieren anerkennen und
wie können wir uns jenseits dieser
tradierten
un-konvention alliierten formen wie zum
beispiel rassismus die können wir uns
anschauen und wirklich diesen blick
ertragen ist der glaube nicht auch nicht
flucht vor der einsamkeit das glaube ich
nicht wissen sie dass das was ich
interessant finde die mystische
erfahrung ist immer verbunden mit
asketischen erfahrung mit der abkehr von
der welt dass wir gott dann sehen wenn
wir gerade uns von der welt ein stück
entfernen es dann sind wir bereit und
fähig die welt zu erkennen theresia es
bei home er war blind aber er heißt sehr
das mag stimmen bis zu einem gewissen
grad aber ich würde dennoch sagen es
gibt hier auch gott in der gemeinschaft
gott in der liebe gott in der art wie
wir zusammen sein können manchmal wenn
ich meine freundinnen anschauen wir sind
zu hause in diesem langen tisch der auch
mal schreibtisches und und wir reden und
brauchen und trinken sprechen bis spät
in die nacht über die dinge die uns
berühren die uns bewegen die uns
beschäftigen die uns gebrochen haben
dann schaue ich diesen tischen und denke
mir was muss eigentlich geschehen sein
was musste passiert sein dass wir uns
hier in dieser stadt berlin haben
treffen können kriege
zerstörungen völkermord mauern sind
gefallen so viele ereignisse von
historischer bedeutung in dieser
geschichte die nur eine schlacht bank
sein kann mussten passieren sind uns
vorausgegangen damit damit er hier sein
können ist das nicht auch ein zeichen
dafür dass gott bei uns ist das bedeutet
der emanuel gott bei uns und wenn ich
das betrachte dann glaube ich die
ästhetische erfahrung ist eine form die
mystische erfahrung in der abkehr ist
eine form gott zu erkennen aber es gibt
auch dieses glück und dieses wunder und
diese tatsache in der ganzen vehemenz
und konsequenz dieses wortes dass wir
uns gefunden haben in der schlechtesten
alle möglichen will
die verkehrung von leibnitz des
philosophen der gesagt hat wir leben in
der besten aller möglichen welten
wir haben über identität gesprochen
über diesen immer versucht er immer
scheitert und selbst auch zu erkennen
bei ihnen ist dieser herkunft speziell
weil sie eigentlich in deutschland
aufgewachsen sind da zur schule gegangen
sind und
jetzt der zeit
lesen wir in den medien von den
protesten seit wochen monaten in sri
lanka der präsident ist zurückgetreten
das land steht vor dem bankrott
was macht es mit ihnen wenn sie jetzt
diese bilder sehen und diese meldung
lesen wissen sie wenn ich ehrlich bin
ich finde ich dabei nichts und ich
empfinde auch keine
emotionale verbundenheit zu diesem land
ich empfinde eine emotionale
verbundenheit und eine existenzielle
verpflichtung den terminen gegenüber
diese menschen die jetzt auf die straße
gehen weil das brot zu teuer ist weil
die benzinpreise zu hoch sind gehen auf
die straße wenn es sie selbst betrifft
aber als 2009 von den menschen in der
jetzigen regierung dieser völkermord zu
ende gebracht worden ist in der
barbarischen und schnellsten
militärischer art ging niemand von
diesen menschen auf die straße und das
ist was mich bestürzt es stehen sie als
größtes es eine pflicht die menschheit
zu legen aber es ist schwer die
menschheit zu leben ich glaube das
schwerste gebot ist das gebot seinen
feind zu leben und für unterdrückte
menschen für menschen die
unterschiedliche formen von
unterdrückung erlebt haben bedeutet die
arbeit der befreiung ja beides nicht nur
dass wir uns befreien müssen vor den
institutionen und den mechanismen die
uns unterdrücken sondern
wir müssen auch die menschen die uns
unterdrücken befreien davon dass sie
unterdrücken das ist die doppelte
dialektik eigentlich die spirale der
arbeit der befreiung und wenn ich das
jetzt sehen was uns lange passiert ich
empfinde nichts ich frage mich nur wie
der grad an barbara muss durch uns
gegangen sein dass diese menschen für
das teure brot für die zu hohen
benzinpreis auf die straße gehen aber
als mehrere zehntausenden menschen in
der kürzesten zeit getötet worden sind
haben sie einen sieg gefeiert
das sind finde ich dabei und dieses zu
teure broten das benzin hängt natürlich
mit einem anderen krieg zu sagen den wir
jetzt verfolgen nämlich in der ukraine
wo viele menschen jetzt flüchten
millionen von von ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer in die schweiz nach deutschland
was ist aus ihrer erfahrung dass das
wichtigste dass das wertvollste was
diesen menschen gegeben werden kann
jetzt
ich kann das so nicht beantworten was
diesen menschen gegeben werden kann aber
was ich weiß ist
das verstehen sie denn noch einmal die
verbindung vielleicht zwischen liebe und
religion deutlich zu machen wenn ich zu
einem menschen sage ich liebe dich dann
sage ich doch nur eines ich sage
ich stehe hier vor dir
bitte nämlich auf weil sie mich nicht
zurück sein ein tempel eine synagoge
meine kirche meine moschee ist meine
zuflucht beschütze mich für mich dorthin
wo ich nicht gehen will aber ich weiß du
wirst bei mir sein ich bitte dich herum
und ich glaube wenn wir das füreinander
sein können diese zuflucht dieser ort
und so heißt das ja bei johannes 64 37
wer zu mir kommt den weiß ich nicht ob
ich glaube wenn wir die einsamkeit als
verfassung verstehen die es uns erlaubt
so miteinander umzugehen uns in unserer
ganzen
trauer hilflosigkeit und ausgesetzt hat
zu sehen wenn ich ein menschenliebe dann
gebe ich diesen menschen mein gesicht
dass ich niemals sehen werde aber ich
weiß dieser mensch wird auf dieses
gesicht aufpassen was ist in den besten
händen in den einzigen händen ich glaube
wenn wir so miteinander umgehen könnten
dann müsste es aber gleichzeitig auch
heißen wie kann es sein dass in
deutschland das die menschen die aus der
ukraine fliegen das ist ein glück für
diese menschen und notwendig und das
mindeste dass sie mit jeder form des
willkommens auch bürokratisch
aufgenommen werden aber warum galt das
nicht für die menschen und gilt das
nicht für den menschen der syring kommen
für die
zahllosen menschen die auf dem
mittelmeer gestorben sind wie kann das
sein dass das für die einen menschen ich
würde sagen für weiße menschen gilt und
für schwarze und braune menschen nicht
geld wissen sie sie hatten fuhren wir
haben vorhin über die theodizee kurz
gesprochen wie kann es möglich sein dass
ein gut ein gütiger gott diese
grausamkeit zulässt ich war vor zwei
jahren in lissabon
ich wollte dorthin gehen aus einem
seltsamen gefühl heraus weil dort der
kolonialismus anfing so lanker
1504 sind die ersten schiffe noch so
lanker gekommen und bis heute sind die
spuren des portugiesischen kolonialismus
es noch anwesend auch missionieren und
auch das christentum ist mit
kolonialismus verbunden und ich war dann
in der kathedrale in lissabon und voller
stolz zeigte der museumsführer mir die
monstranz wenn ich mich richtig erinnere
eineinhalb meter hoch und er sagte das
gold kommt aus sri lanka die edelsteine
kann muss mosambik aus brasilien aus
angola also aus den früheren
portugiesischen kolonie
als 1755 lissabon durch das große
erdbeben den tsunami zerstört worden ist
hat voltaire und die ganze westliche
philosophie angefangen die theodizee
infrage zu stellen ich kann es möglich
sein das zu den zu allerheiligen in
diesem erzkatholischen land das passiert
wie kann ein gott das zulassen und was
ich mich frage und das sind ja
intellektuelle auf die wir heute immer
noch referieren auf die wir immer noch
zurückkommen ist folgendes nämlich wie
kann es sein dass die ganze barbarische
geschichte des kolonialismus ist die
versklavten menschen die tausenden
versklavt menschen eine küste portugals
angekommen sind dass sie nicht dazu
geführt haben dass
europa sich gefragt hat wie kann ein
gültiger ein guter gottes zu lassen
das muss sie es selbst treffen und ich
frage mich schon man kann auch sagen das
waren freie menschen die das gemacht
haben das erdbeben das hat kein mensch
verursacht das stimmt aber es war ja
auch möglich nur so zu denken weil
manche menschen nicht als menschen
galten sie waren weniger als ein mensch
das ist ja was rassismus tut und was
sehen wird und dass es was mich traurig
macht ich bin glücklich über alle
ukrainerinnen die jetzt so viel ich
meine natürlich in diesem unglück dass
sie fliehen mussten überhaupt aber dass
ihnen nicht diese schwierigkeiten diese
bürokratischen hürden in den weg gelegt
werden ich frage mich schon warum sind
manche menschen weniger mensch warum ist
es für europa in ordnung dass so viele
menschen auf dem weg zu dieser festung
im mittelmeer trinken und anderen
menschen wird es erlaubt so einfach und
so selbstverständlich aus den richtigen
gründen hier so aufgenommen zu werden
ist glaube für sie eine form von einem
utopischen heimweh von von einem von
einer art von geborgenheit nachdem man
sich sehnt
ich würde eher sagen man weiß es nie
geben wird wissen sie wenn wir den
begriff der erlösung uns anschauen
christentum dann gibt es ja eine
deutliche dramaturgie es gibt gott als
handelnde entität akteur und es gibt den
erlösen des bedürftigen menschen aber
was ist wenn wir
unsere vorstellung der lösungen nicht
auch von jenseits projizieren was ist
wenn wir sagen es ist unsere aufgabe als
in dem fall eben auch als christinnen zu
sagen wir müssen einen zustand in dieser
welt
erreichen in dem es möglich ist dass
eigentlich der
wunsch nach erlösung nicht mehr
vorhanden ist und es möglich ist dass
wir leben können alle menschen
jenseits von unterdrückung von barbara
von den institutionen der gewalt in der
es möglich ist verstehen sie ich bin
jedes mal staunt darüber die
herzlichkeit von kapitalistischer
politik von
neo liberalen ansichten
hat nicht jeder mensch das recht
fair zu bild bezahlt zu werden für seine
und ihre arbeit
wohnraum zu erhalten
und einen lohn für die arbeit zu
bekommen der nicht für den mindestbedarf
leben unterhalt nahrung verwendet werden
muss es gibt diese eine geschichte die
ich oft denke walter jens der no
ehemalige rhetorik professor in tübingen
erzählt sie von johann gottlieb fichte
dem berühmten philosophen der
klassischen deutschen philosophie der
bände perspektive der geschichte nur ein
bindeglied geworden ist zwischen kant
und hegel fichte kommt aus einer
ärmlichen familie berichtete war
talentiert fichte hatte eine
einzigartige auffassungsgabe und der
gutsherr von mild jetzt hat er einmal
die predigt verpasst also wurde der
junge fichte 67 jahre zu ihm geschickt
und er konnte den fahrer so
präzise imitieren das
gute von miltitz fichte die ausbildung
finanziert fichte konnte die
landesschule in
schulpforte besuchen auf der auch später
nietzsche war und aus diesem jungen aus
den ärmlichsten verhältnissen ist
einer der wesentlichen philosophen der
deutschen philosophie geworden ist sagt
walter jens ist es eine schöne
geschichte nein wie viele junge fichte
wie viele junge genies gab es den nicht
auf einen von miltitz gestoßen sind
walter jens sagte müssen die geschichte
schreiben aus der perspektive der
verhinderten genies ich würde
weitergehen wir müssen die geschichte
schreiben aus der perspektive der
menschen
die nie so leben konnten wie sie es
eigentlich sich gewünscht habe hatten
die
geschichte müssen wir betrachten aus der
perspektive der un- verwirklichten
manuskripte der menschen die vielleicht
schreiben wollten aber den nie in die
lage und in die gelegenheit gekommen
sind schreiben zu können erlösung
bedeutet für mich das ist ein begriff
der unser diesseits meint und unsere
hände und unser mund ist gefragt und wir
müssen es schaffen einen zustand zu
erreichen eine welt zu
bauen in der niemand mehr das bedürfnis
nach erlösung hat
wie sehen sie ihre eigene rolle als
schriftsteller
apropos hände und mund
das wenig was literatur kann es
vielleicht die magie nation zu biegen
und das ist ja auch das was literatur
philosophie und theologie mich
miteinander für mich verbindet was
passiert in uns jenseits unserer
vorstellungskraft bewegen rassismus
bedeutet ein mensch hat uns zu einem
bildnis gemacht er hat eine bestimmte
vorstellung von uns und es gibt diesen
schönen brief von von kafka
1903 am 8 november sondern freund oskar
polak
adressiert verlassen sind wir doch wie
verehrte kinder im wald und wenn du vor
mir stehst was weißt du denn von den
schmerzen in mir was weiß ich den
vereinen und wenn ich mich vor den
niederwerfen würde und weinen und
erzählen was müsstest du mehr von mehr
als von dem eingang der hölle von dem
dir jemand einmal erzählt hat sie sehr
heiß und fürchterlich genau deshalb
müssen wir vor einem menschen so
ehrfürchtig zu nachdenklich so liebe
entstehen wie vor dem eingang zur hölle
und ich glaube das ist für mich
eigentlich natur sich keine ebenbild zu
machen und vor einem menschen aus dieser
demut aus dieser perspektive der demo zu
stehen das heißt aber letzten endes auch
dass die imagination immer wieder
erweitert immer wieder geprüft werden
als 2016 neben meinem debüt noch drei
andere bücher von autorinnen bei der
großen deutschen publikumsverlagen
erschienen sind die zum ersten mal von
transnationalen fluchtbewegungen
migrationsbewegungen erzählt hatten
schilder bei sie nachts leiser therapie
jahre waren
am ende fallen die zedern sascha khayat
weil wir längst woanders sind war das
was neues verstehen sie es gab
geschichten zur pflicht und migration in
der deutschsprachige tattoo habe sie kam
vor allem von osteuropäischen autorinnen
jetzt zum beispiel findet man bei jedem
publikumsverlagen bücher zu migration
und flucht und ich möchte darauf wert
legen flucht und migration sind zwei
verschiedene dinge migration kennt ein
ende flucht nicht flucht ist uns immer
voraus flucht es ein anderer logistische
aber auch an andere juristen schon ein
existenzieller weg als migration auf
diesen unterschied müssen wir haben aber
was ich mich schon fragen folgendes wie
viele menschen wollten küche schreiben
wie diese und konnten das nicht tun weil
lektorinnen verlage agentinnen das nicht
als tattoo angesehen haben dem ich die
würde der literatur gegeben hatten und
jetzt ist für mich schon folgende frage
virulent ja es wird vom verlagswesen
diese einer erzählung der flucht der
migration nicht weißen auto rinnen
autorinnen in diesen biografien
zugestanden aber was wenn wir daraus
heraustreten und das ist was dieses
zweite ob dieser zweite roman eigentlich
tut zu sagen es gibt die geschichte
dieses landes
diese eine geschichte die uns
zugesprochen zugestanden wird es gibt
die geschichte unserer eltern die uns
auch eine zukunft weisen wollte die
nicht unsere zukunft ist aber was ist
wenn wir uns jenseits all dieser
imaginationen der
mehrheitsgesellschaft unsere eltern der
sogenannten kultur des herkunftslandes
und es der kultur des aufnahmelandes
bewegen dann sind wir doch alleine wir
sind vollkommen ausgesetzt in diesen
nicht aber in diesem nichts können wir
anderes finden in dem wir alles vorher
es verloren haben
damit haben sie den bogen geschlossen
zum anfang zu diesem nichts dass da war
bevor gott die welt erschuf wo das
potenzial die möglichkeit aber
sie gaben mir sehr viel zu denken
das gespräch werden auch nicht danke
ihnen ganz herzlich ein daran war das st
ja danke ihnen fürs fürs mit denken wenn
sie nun lust bekommen haben auf die
bücher meines heutigen gastes wir
verlosen je zwei ich signierte exemplare
schreiben sie mir einfach entweder auf
instagram oder auf unserer website unter
der rubrik mehr zur sendung nächste
woche spricht barbara bleisch mit der
autorin ronja von rönne über das thema
depression und über den trotzdem hier im
leben brauchen und jetzt gleich folgt
das abstimmung studio bleiben dran und
bis bald
[Musik]